Donald Trump just finished up his third
vacation at his mar-a-lago of resort in
Florida and three weeks these trips have
included some pretty horrible stuff
including that embarrassing public
situation what I like to call the North
Korean missile launch dinner debacle
where he just in front of in a patio in
front of mar-a-lago guests was
discussing a recent North Korean missile
launch with the Japanese Prime Minister
Shinzo Abe a also this is a big business
benefit for Trump that's never far
behind this raises Morrow logos profile
mar-a-lago is constantly being mentioned
in the media this is again a for-profit
club that the Trump family makes money
off of being trafficked and and
frequented by guests the Washington Post
is reporting that these trips tomorrow
logo three trips have cost US taxpayers
about 10 million dollars okay that's
about three million dollars per trip
this includes Coast Guard and other
military activation it includes Secret
Service it includes additional staffing
and then you've also seen Trump Sons
take some business-related trips which
required very extensive security on the
government dime meaning taxpayers this
is putting total Trump family travel
expenses at eleven point three million
dollars in taxpayer money during the
first month of the presidency context
time this is roughly what President
Obama spent on travel for an entire year
of his presidency he was spending about
12.1 million per year of his presidency
on travel Republicans said it was
outrageous every time you went to
Martha's Vineyard it was a scandal every
time he went to Hawaii was a scandal
Donald Trump spent his month
as much as Obama was spending in a year
Pat in one month I'm hearing silence
from Republicans yeah especially after
we broke all those campaign promises I
mean I think he just kind of learned
that he can be a figurehead and delegate
out all the responsibilities giving
people like Steve Bannon and Steven
Miller and maybe that's it's bad in a
way because those people could be even
more deplorable than he is yeah but if
you're if you're spending all this money
still and traveling around there's
really just no way to justify it if
you're not actually doing the
work you know and maybe he is I mean I
know the president can work from
anywhere in blah blah blah but that's
not really what it's about it's about
the fact that Trump himself was critical
of Obama for his trips as well this also
I'm just talking to you about the Trump
numbers Trump and his wife Melania
aren't living together she's living in
New York City and that has cost an
additional 15 million so far which by
the way is also great for Donald Trump's
business because by having Melania in
New York City at Trump Tower the
government is paying millions in rent to
the Trump Organization to stay at Trump
Tower themselves because hey Melania is
there and we need to be that the first
lady needs to have her staff around so
as usual with Trump the double standards
and the contradictions are numerous
number one Trump said that he would
rarely vacation he said that multiple
times he would rarely leave the White
House as president that's the
contradiction because he's doing it all
the time okay so that's a campaign why
number two Trump claims to be an
advocate of fiscal conservatism in
theory obviously that's BS but he claims
to be an advocate of fiscal conservatism
it's not exactly fiscally conservative
to spend as much per month as President
Obama was spending per year on travel
expenses and layer-3 is and will start
to show you some some of the data around
this layers three is that Trump himself
previously slammed President Obama for
the vacations that he took okay so we
have one tweet from last year where
Donald Trump said taxpayers are paying a
fortune for the use of Air Force One on
the campaign trail by President Obama
and crooked Hillary a total disgrace and
then also a Trump tweet from 2014 where
he said I say we cannot continue to like
Obama fly around on Air Force One at a
cost of millions of dollars a day for
the purpose of politics and play
politics in play Trump's played about
six or seven rounds of golf while down
at mar-a-lago when he was flown down
there on Air Force One does that qualify
Pat as the type of flying around on Air
Force One for play that President Obama
was slammed for I think the exact same
thing I think I mean and Trump has said
that he's not going to accept the
presidential salary of four hundred
thousand dollars that drop in the bucket
compared to this and if he really is a
billionaire he should be able to
compensate
American taxpayer for this 11 million
dollars just so far on the first month
Trump said in 2015 to a reporter I would
rarely leave the White House because
there's so much work to be done I would
not be a president who took vacations I
would not be a president who takes time
off you don't have time to take time off
apparently Donald Trump does and Trump
has also criticized how much golf Obama
played and again a few days ago Trump
played his sixth round of golf as
president averaging more than a round of
golf per week the White House admitted
that they have been misleading the media
about how much golf Donald Trump has
been playing all the time we have not
only the hypocrisy and the double
standards but we have the lies and
deception from the Trump team and in the
midst of all the travel expenses Trump's
team just put together a budget proposal
which would cut money from things like
the Corporation for Public Broadcasting
the National endowments for the Arts the
human for the Arts and the humanities
all of these really important programs
including some for low-income
individuals like the Legal Services
Corporation and AmeriCorps as Pat said
drops in the bucket Trump is a walking
contradiction his entire campaign was a
lie and the Republicans are not far
behind because they were slamming Obama
every time he flew anywhere for a
vacation I've heard no complaints from
Republicans about what Trump is doing
also I mean Donald Trump during his
business career was was considered to be
a branding expert I mean this is kind of
obvious PR if you criticize the previous
president for playing too much golf and
going on too many vacations you'd think
you would just do you wouldn't do the
same thing right he'd have the PR savvy
if nothing else even if he has the
desire to go play golf even if he
doesn't care about the fact that he's
not working when he said he would you
would think that just for the PR benefit
and the optics he would avoid doing this
but Trump is above that he doesn't care
and or doesn't get it please take a
survey at POD survey dot-com / Pakman
that's PA que ma n pod serve a.com slash
Pakman we're gathering information to
hopefully bring on some new advertiser
to the David Pakman show over the next
six to twelve months and we need to
collect this survey data so please help
us out pod survey comm slash Pakman I'm
on Twitter at D Pakman the show is on
twitter at david pakman show and we'll
be right back after this
today's show is brought to you by go
daddy where you can buy your own domain
name build a website or use any of Go
Daddy's business tools you can save 30%
at try go daddy.com slash David GoDaddy
has actually been the official host of
the David Pakman show web site for many
many many years the 24/7 customer
support has been a very good thing for
us I've called them at really odd times
when we've had website issues and they
are always available they are the
largest domain registrar and whether you
have a new idea you're an established
business you're creating a personal
website or moving your large enterprise
site over to GoDaddy they can do it all
thirteen million customers try it and
get 30% off at try go daddy.com slash
david